service level objectives or SLO s are
one of the fundamental principles of
site reliability engineering will use
them to precisely quantify the
reliability target we want to achieve in
our service but how do we measure them
and what do we do when our SLO
monitoring tells us that there's a
problem with service monitoring we can
track our SLO s and air budgets and
quickly respond to our service is having
an issue this is a stack dr first let's
review the basics you may have heard of
SL o--'s but what's an SLI let's clearly
define both of those our overall
objective here is to accurately quantify
reliability and measure our user
happiness the actual thing we'll use as
a proxy for that it's called the service
level indicator or SLI we need to define
that indicator for our service an easy
place to start is by using one of our
golden signals we'll put the link to the
monitoring chapter of the SR e book
where those are explained in a notes
below you can also watch the excellent
video created by Liz and Seth that
explains this topic in greater detail
we'll link to that too
generally SL eyes fall into two
categories request based SL is measure
the fraction of good units of work
against the total for example what
percentage of a request in a HTTP
endpoint were successful in a given time
window window based SL eyes measure the
fraction of time intervals during which
the service meets some threshold over a
given time window let's use an example
if we have an app engine service we can
use the response count metric as our SLI
specifically we can count our good
responses by filtering that metric for
only responses that return an HTTP 200
and use the unfiltered value to count
our total responses we divide the two to
arrive at the fraction or ratio of good
to total and that's our SLI now let's
talk about SL owes a service level
objective is the target value for SLI
measured over time it's generally
comprised of three things the SLI a
target for the SLI and a window over
which is measured called a compliance
period so for our simple HTTP service we
may set our SLO as 99% of requests
returned HTTP 200 for the last 28 days
our air budget then is essentially the
inverse of the SLO and it's example
we're expecting that 1% of our requests
will fail every day
now that we have that sorted out let's
take a look at how we can use the
service monitoring API to create track
and alert on our SL O's first we define
our SLI on SLO using a JSON payload and
send it to the API to create them there
are four key elements here the good
service filter and total service filter
or how we specify how we're counting
good and total requests the goal is the
actual objective for the SLO the target
we want to meet and the rolling period
is the time window over which we want to
evaluate our SLI once our SLO is created
who can then create in the learning
policy using SLO burn rate as the
condition type we want to be notified if
our service consumes err budget at an
elevated rate in the alerting policy we
specify the threshold the percentage of
error budget consumed and the look-back
duration the period over which that
consumption can happen for our service
experience is an issue our learning
policy will create an inset the snow
that our error budget burn rate is too
high we then know that our service
quality is degraded and we should take
immediate action to resolve the issue
now that we have service monitoring
setup and alerting for service issues
configured it can be much more confident
they'll be able to deliver on our
service level objectives and keep our
users happy thanks for joining me today
that's it for this episode this is the
stack dr. stay healthy out there
[Music]
you
[Music]